[Music]
hello everyone in January 2012 a
mysterious organization released an
intricate puzzle on the internet saying
it was looking for highly intelligent
individuals the group issued a new
puzzle for following two years until its
latest one couldn't be solved it remains
a mystery to those who still are trying
to crack it four years later no one
knows who's behind the puzzle or how the
latest piece can be decoded find of
these solvers continue against all odds
and who might give us insight into the
mind behind cicada 3301 the key has
always been right in front of your eyes
good luck three three zero one
[Music]
it's a kid I believed that could sow a
little seed of curiosity into the mass
of people
to think about how to create a society
in which the open exchange of
information is encouraged
[Music]
if cicadas shot anything at us they
really like to get people to think about
how things fit together and how they can
be rearranged in order to create new
things it may put you on the map to
intelligence agencies because you dabble
with breaking encryption you dabble with
a certain kind of hacker culture and
ethos you expose yourself and you may be
a threat to some people
[Music]
I'm brother box actually I don't want to
talk about a match people are not
supposed to know my age actually I will
just give a brief brief introduction
about myself my name is brother box I
live in Germany I study IT security I
remember I played my first computer game
at around four that didn't understand
much because they were all in English
and that kinda had to guess my way
around that was actually a motivation
for me to learn English because I was
tired of asking grown-ups what things
meant only my brother knows that I'm at
all and educator I keep it away from
most people because most people don't
connect with us around
hackers are riven by the urge to know
things and mostly about the things that
they don't know because a hacker
considers the fact that someone may
forbid you to know something as a threat
to their own curiosity I believe that
the people that are behind cicada are
driven by much the same mindset when I
started with cicada I was the guy who
asked the questions I was the guy who
was slow in learning now I am the person
that gets asked these questions I like
to believe that I'm one of the most
rigorous and thorough members of our
community people value my word and my
judgement our community is a bit
different when you're part of us you're
kind of part of us and every time you
form this bond
I first got to know Annan in 2012 but
I've never met him he is not necessarily
a part of the core team but I think this
entire operation would be Porter without
him
[Music]
about you Teegarden talk to em why shop
America decision mr. long where does it
kinda broke up with me device economy to
see can depositors usually wrap up
within a month this puzzle has persisted
and denied us any resolve for three
years I believe lever promise is
solvable but at this point only a very
fresh mind can do it someone who looks
at things in a completely different way
under my total happiness company from
sneers overhead a spartan in Essen that
f king about artistic on this plaintiff
onyx demise publish a modulus long niche
unofficially as long as I was in delight
and she does it's much madam as much
account knocks and I don't be a
statistician and implement that so only
one sponsor dimension is a sphere can be
implemented zone from one canonical si
si Perkins mathematician even saw a
copper I had a sturdy a dish net spin
yang tree attempt Libya
Nadal there'd be reversed
the Stasi traffic noise in gotta come
with us our phones go vistas
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice cars man dr. cha cha
to effectively solves a kid and you have
to have a very inquisitive mind and you
have to be technically capable and I
believe that in cicadas mindset it was
important to connect these people into
one central hub we took a lot of time
and a lot of effort trying to solve
level promise and I would like to
resolve that piece of their legacy so
maybe we can all move on something it is
that itch that you can't scratch and you
want to scratch it so bad hops okay so
take a look so this here is this message
well in 2016 is a year and a half before
they released this picture you see this
large box
yeah that's outcaste no it's not yeah so
doesn't this look a lot like that tree
when I zoomed in on it on page 32 maybe
that's an angle that we should at least
think about you see how on page it what
is it
57 we are using just good old gematria
right which I did not believe to be a
coincidence in 2013 we had gotten the
translation from ruins to English and we
didn't know what to do with them back
then because we had new ruins in 2014 we
finally got the first ruins on the
second to last page of the ruins they
say there is a page of the Deep Web and
it is the duty of every pilgrim to find
this page for the longest time we had no
idea what it could be we tried a lot of
stuff on tour the scanning tour to find
websites
we found some interesting stuff but not
cicada the deep web is a fast and
unmapped space and unless you know what
you want to find in it you're probably
not going to find it what if we use
plain text on page 57 is the key on
those pages 23 through 26 because it's a
mirrored mayfly the same mayfly that's
on fifty-seven whole idea literally
anything usable but those possibly
repeated words it is gonna be the most
anyone's got on this and piers
are the keys to breaking the Libra prime
is hidden in history
[Music]
the importance of cryptography and
code-breaking
goes back millennia as long as we've had
a need to communicate we've also had a
need to keep those communications secret
even Julius Caesar would send encoded
messages for his generals to read on the
battlefield in much more recent history
the world as we know it might have been
dramatically different if it weren't for
England's own group of cryptographic
solvers disrupting German communications
during for too
Bletchley Park was home to their
top-secret code breaking operation
during the war the German High Command
would send encrypted messages all over
the battlefields of Europe in North
Africa
by 1945 you've got nearly 10,000 people
working here three shifts 24 hours a day
processing huge amounts of intelligence
they were confident in the security of
these highly sensitive communications
because of their secret weapon it was
called enigma oh my god that's it that's
it that's an any good machine it's not a
radio set it doesn't communicate it just
encrypts let me show you how that
happens
yes what this does is if you press a
letter any key you like I'm gonna press
P Missy why isn't it up right the clever
part is if I press P again I don't get
why I get a different letter for every
key press it completely changes the
encryption knowing how it functioned was
the start of a story but it's not the
end of the story by any means what
helped them break this machine to
understand the messages sent on it was
to understand basically how the
operators misused it the key to breaking
enigma was cribbing if you could guess
part of a message and you knew what
letters spell that plaintext you could
then offer that up against the
ciphertext and start to establish
relationships one of the mistakes the
Germans made was to be predictable in
their language common words were things
like weather forecasts and Germans have
weather ships at Atlantic that sent
weather forecasts back every day so
every day they're sending a message the
first word of which is weather forecasts
if you know which those messages are
we've got a crib into them so you use
the really dull boring messages that you
can guess the content of to unlock the
ones that have the real secrets in how
does the lessons of enigma help us solve
cicada just look at the seek sequence of
runes one option is to use cribs to
guess phrases that you think might be
what that message says
and if you do that you can then see
patterns between the runes and your
plaintext characters and these are the
tools that cryptography used throughout
history did you say that the English for
German curse words yeah they were
cribben for wires in German because they
knew about the length of them and the
Germans wouldn't stop swearing at each
other that and weather reports are the
two biggest things they used for
cribbing when trying to fix that's me
I'm twelve thousand percent fed up
without guess I don't want to hear that
word ever again we're just gonna go over
what we've done in like the last week or
so the long and short of that is we got
this giant list which is every giant
string of runes that you've tried to
encrypt you look of you a numerical
value of its fitness with English it
looks like it has a great strength and a
great weakness because it checks for
engrams in order which could be helpful
for partially decrypted words this was
used when they were getting partial
decryptions on so that's what we did
this weekend I don't remember I don't
remember days we have done so much
automation on this that the actual
solution if there is one is probably one
that has to be guided by a human brain
we need something more advanced my part
is we need to put our beautiful little
heads to it
[Music]
around 11 o'clock at night is usually
when we all kind of get together for our
hangouts we go for maybe 3 or 4 hours
almost every night I also spend some
time outside of it thinking about it
there's a lot of that in computing where
you're not working and typing it because
you don't really know yet how to form it
do you have to think it through and then
you just go people have been so burned
out trying this so many people have
thrown up her hands they get frustrated
with this because it's like a big wall
of text if Craig could help us even
decrypt one page that would be the
biggest break we've had since 2014 hey
how's it going
one cool is connecting with Craig Bauer
one of the world's top crypto experts in
hopes of gaining some insight in order
to crack the Libra Primus powers a
former resident historian in the NSA and
has literally written the book on famous
unsolved puzzles gematria Primus this
was what they revealed in one of the
puzzles and that was used directly to
decode some pages so it's a mapping from
rune to English letter very last page of
this it translates directly here to P
the next one was a so this says parable
so it was the last page the only one
that was a substitution cipher that's a
great question
the second to last page was encrypted
with the stream of numbers so that gave
us the message that said we had to seek
out a page on the Deep Web they said
it's everybody's duty to define
I mean we know that cicada is obsessed
with prime numbers forgetting about you
know this this room correspondence it
sounds like they have really modern
implementations like steganography and
things you have to look for throughout
guess yeah it's not just flat-out math
math math right yeah maybe the key is
text in which case Friedman's attack and
it's generalizations would be a good
approach William Friedman was a
geneticist who took on cryptography as a
hobby he later became the first chief
cryptologist at the NSA Friedman
invented a technique of putting two
texts side-by-side and counting the
number of times that identical letters
appear in the same position in both
texts Friedman's attack looked at the
frequency certain letters appear and was
thereby able to determine whether it was
a simple or a complex encoded message
while this may not sound like much it
greatly reduces the nearly infinite
possibilities you have to try on a
puzzle like the libra Primus so
Friedman's attack would basically look
at the pairings most likely to give you
the letter you see so that's very
infrequent letters then you can kind of
discard and focus on the common English
letters right yes you might be missing a
few letters where rare letters came into
play but it'd just be like reading a
book with a lot of type boats really wow
that's that's fascinating because it's
kind of like taking the analysis we've
done and really taking it a step further
because I hadn't I've never heard of
that and those are kind of the types of
ciphers that are great to know about
because we've really been stuck we can't
drop the problem so we're gonna try this
and I'll kind of get back to the guys
about your thoughts on it I'm sure
you've been in the situation where
you're like I need to figure it out and
I can't just let it go because you
you're stubborn sure I'm just pleased
and they gave a little bit of a prod to
someone to do that and now maybe it'll
come full circle and it helped us if you
weren't persistent you wouldn't be
attacking ciphers I mean it demands that
kind of personality yeah
[Music]
Knox and I are headed to meet a Lanka
deunan
she's a noted codebreaker best known for
her expertise with the CIA's kryptos
puzzle
she even runs her own solving community
attempting to break the puzzles famous
last section can you help us put cicada
in some type of context of you know
crypto puzzles of the larger world that
you're so familiar with you know more
about the details of what's going on cuz
I have people send me codes two three
times a week I can I show you if we're
sure typically the sort of classical
cryptography letter shifting visionnaire
all that sort of style of cryptography
they don't do as much of a lot of what
they've done has been like RSA break a
key so this really we were kind of
unprepared for what they gave us which
is a 58 encrypted pages either every
section or every page has a different
encoding like encryption okay we've only
we've only decrypted to okay in three
years
you're welcome to like look through it
as much as you want this one the key was
it's a running key the length of the
page that's the and it's the totient of
the prime sequence so it's yeah like
where you see the issues were having
we've been doing a lot with the log
probabilities of quad rams and trigrams
you really want to solve this yeah
that's great okay so I'm just trying to
build my mental maps so I'm just
brainstorming okay as I'm looking
through so the first thing is I'm
looking at the marginalia
is it the same on each page no and
almost none of it we've actually
identified what it supposed this looks
like bacon I don't mean Frances bacon
yeah interesting good number okay keep
going I never heard that this also could
be bacon cipher hmm
so I tend to think about the psychology
of whoever's creating this whoever's
creating these is thinking wow I got a
lot of smart people that are gonna crack
this within weeks you know days I got to
make something really hard let's assume
that it's the same person that it's one
person I would want to see all the
different puzzles that they've done kind
of all lined up mm-hmm that's one of the
ways I cracked codes is not cracking the
code but understanding the mind of who
created them like some of these hacker
codes that I've cracked some of it is
code solving but some of it is okay who
wrote this okay was this guy it was the
guy who runs the convention okay when
did he write this he probably wrote it
the day before the convention because he
was late on everything else
so he's sleep-deprived he's probably
drunk what kinds of mistakes are they
gonna make there instead of shifting
left they're gonna shift right and I'm
sorry like oh look there's the word that
right and then the rest of it just kind
of goes right right but what if there is
no answer what if someone created this
and they they just they're obviously
computer savvy and maybe they wrote
something to generate random runes so
this dump may not be solvable yeah yeah
it's absolutely crossed my mind and kind
of horrified me that I might I might be
working on something impossible you want
to see this salt I can tell you got the
fire why I mean for me in the long run
if sick cicada is unsolvable if I never
find out who it is the things I've
learned especially and the people I've
met and learned from them along the way
has been so worth it that if it's a 17
year old kid laughing about it that's
fine because I learned this much about
cryptography
ilan khmer dag rate point when she said
we needed to get into the mind of the
creator we found a great potential lead
he's one of the world's top puzzle
makers and he created a game with a
connection to cicada we can't ignore
[Music]
adrián Han is a leader in the field of
what's called a RGS were alternate
reality games his clients include
corporations and media outlets looking
to build buzz around their content and
his games have been played by millions
of devoted fans does it surprise you
that puzzles and secret codes so appeals
to us you know people want to believe
that there is a sense of order in the
universe you know you have people who
from the dawn of time they look up and
they look at the Stars and they think
why are the stars in these shapes you
know why is a flood today that's always
been this appeal of people trying to
understand the world and other people
trying to create puzzles to hide aaalac
maybe to make themselves seem more
mysterious or more powerful than they
really are
in early 2011 year approached to create
a suite of puzzles in support of this
BBC show on mathematics called the code
correct they want to make mathematics
more interesting for a younger audience
young people like games so let's see if
we can go and turn learning how
mathematics interactive nature into the
TV show everything from fine numbers
geometry and how birds flock together
and we think how can we use those
concepts in a treasure hunt and weave
them into the program as you know the
one that interests us most is the very
first one why cicadas cicadas are known
for having a gestation period which is
linked to prime numbers fine numbers are
at the heart of nature and a heart of
mathematics that puzzle comes out in
June 2011 yeah
six months later cicada 3301 makes its
international debut it's a it's a big
coincidence there are some people who
have brought up the fact that whoever's
behind the cicada 3301 would have to be
a very accomplished game maker sure he
would be a candidate to be that person
that's true
I mean cicada 3301 has a lot in common
with the games we've made I think that's
one big difference is it normally when
we make alternate reality games we do it
for money
and it's not so clear so understand
where the funding for cicada 3301 is
coming from would you be disappointed or
secretly thrilled if 30 years from now
we still don't know whose cicada 3301 is
I'd be delighted it no one knows why is
because I think that when most of these
puzzles that we make are made to be
solved and clearly this is a very
different one not everything has to be
solved overnight maybe I'll take 50
years or 100 years in it
it's better my name is shadow Walker and
I live on the internet now the game is
can you keep your identity secret we do
amazing things here at NSA every time
there's this government intervention
you're going okay which side are we
getting this is the rule that we're
living in this is what we need to kid if
you release this tool and you save
somebody's life is it still a game
[Music]